if there's something strange in the
neighborhood well with all due respect
to the Ghostbusters if I'm being
attacked by a spook Specter ghost or a
free-floating full-torso vaporous
apparition I'm not calling for graduate
school dropout no I'm either dialing up
the Winchester brothers or I'm gassing
up from this dream machine Scooby in the
game these guys there are frickin role
models man except Brett he's a wad
today it's scooby-doo versus
supernatural for the crown of the
all-time best battlers of the bellowing
points scooby-doo shaggy and the gang
have been a worldwide institution for
generations of fans meanwhile Sam and
Dean Winchester have cultivated an
impressive 15 year run thanks to a
legion of diehard supporters whether the
enemy du jour is ghost werewolves or mr.
withers who runs the old amusement park
these two teams of lovable underdogs
always get the job done but what happens
when they face off against each other
soit's here's how we'll determine a
winner
round 1 tomato meter round 2 popularity
round 3 characters and then we'll do a
wildcard round to settle the score once
and for all
I'll then say goodnight then it's up to
you the home viewer to cast your vote
the mystery gang is taken on the
Winchester family and a whole box of
Scooby Snax are on the line I once ate a
milk-bone out of there what's getting on
clear eyes with clogged arteries
Danlos not one tomato meter everyone and
their mother and their grandmother and
their great grandma's ghost has heard of
scooby-doo and supernatural has enough
hardcore fans to populate an entire
country but how do the critics feel
about these celebrated franchises ok
Winchester's y'all want to take a crack
at this one first
the boys and their gaggle of relatives
friends and spooky enemies appear to be
BFFs with a tomato meter whether you've
never heard of supernatural or you're a
hardcore fan you're gonna need to brace
yourself because the show has an overall
average of 93% what and that's not one
out of a thousand that's out of a
hundred that's an A average kids the
show's lowest the season was
at 63% which is still fresh and the show
can boast multiple perfect seasons at a
hundred percent including its currently
ongoing 15 season wait so the current
season is still perfect okay nobody
talked to in the dugout leave it alone
do not jinx this we have work to do you
may be saying to yourself okay mark you
handsome hunk of granite 93 percent is
good but scooby-doo is beloved right
well not necessarily by the critics so
we don't have tomato meter scores for
the original CBS or ABC runs of the show
but we do have them for the more recent
live-action and animated features and
only average is 50% 50% in what twisted
world could you possibly rate a ghost
fighting dog rotten
despite sizable box-office success
it appears the live-action films
starring Matthew Lillard Linda
Cardellini sir Michelle Gellar and my
close personal friend Freddie Prinze jr.
are considered rowdy
they averaged his 26% however a handful
of the animated films are fresh with
scooby-doo on Zombie Island taking the
top franchise score at 86% and that
movie came out like a decade before the
walking dead so Scooby you were ahead of
the curve you hear the screeching
[Music]
so despite the mystery gangs good looks
and sense of humor it's the other sect
of funny honks that's gonna take round
number one supernatural has a
good-enough tomato meter scored to get
into an Ivy League school and that's why
it's going up 1-nothing
on Scooby round 2 popularity to all the
kids out there watching being popular
it's not a big deal
follow your own path march to the beat
of your own drummer unless of course
you're trying to win around to this show
then being cool and lovable really helps
real I mentioned the mystery teams
foibles as it pertains to critics on the
tomato meter but Scooby does rebound
when it comes to the audience score him
in the gang making into fresh territory
barely at 62%
however supernatural continues its
sterling fresh record with a healthy B
average of 86 percent and according to
the audience between seasons 3 & 5 of
the show Supernatural enjoyed a
three-year high of 95 percent meanwhile
the two series what's new Scooby Doo and
Scooby and Shaggy get a clue each have a
perfect 100 percent although 2018 s
Daphne and Velma only garnered 37% why
is that so low I like Daphne and Velma
did Scrappy Doo show up and ruin it
[ __ ] doing the next round popularity
can also be determined by a question as
simple as does anyone watch your show
Sam Dean and the gang certainly have
solid ratings that strengthen their case
for the first fourteen seasons of
supernatural it averaged two point three
five million viewers per episode and
that's all the more impressive
considering it originally aired on the
CW and not one of the major networks
fans were on board with the brothers
from the start a season one set a show
record of 3 point 8 1 million viewers
per week however many more fans like
yours truly didn't really discover the
greatness of Supernatural until it was
available on streaming platforms like
Netflix as a matter of fact I think the
first time I saw it I had a DVD mailed
to B by Netflix I missed the medieval
times but one chance speech rootsy when
he knows
scooby-doo obviously goes way further
back into human and dog history the show
debuted in 1969 and has been in the
public consciousness ever since and even
though the ratings for all the various
incarnations of Scooby are murky at best
I can report that in 1969 sixty-five
percent of households were tuned into
CBS on Saturday morning where it
originally aired that's gonna sell a lot
of Anacin and talcum powder Scooby does
have the advantage of having been on the
big screen
turning out to live-action hits early on
in this millennium scooby-doo and its
sequel monsters unleashed combined for
an impressive 384 million dollars
domestically and 740 million dollars
worldwide apparently people love dogs
and they're stoned owners furthering the
taste for the Mystery Machine is the
Cartoon Network phenomenon check this
scooby-doo the mystery begins premiered
in 2009 and broke virtually every record
that channel had it got 6 million
viewers then the next year its follow-up
curse of the lake monster garnered 5
million views both were good for the
number 1 telecast of the year on Cartoon
Network sure it's a bit of a lopsided
battle having a TV show battle another
TV show that also has movies but maybe
there was a reason Scooby got to be on
the silver screen in the first place but
before I give up on the Winchesters in
this round let's see how many episodes
they've made Wow
really 327 supernatural shows will have
been made by the end of the run I've
never done 327 of anything in my life
well that one thing dude were you on my
computer other than that but look
scooby-doo can even top that gaudy
number because his gang has 376 episodes
over 16 different shows 5 animated TV
films 2 theatrically released movies 42
animated direct-to-dvd films 6
direct-to-dvd specials 3 direct-to-dvd
live action movies 35 web shorts 537
comic book issues oh okay we get the
point
Scooby's popular and he gets a snack
because his squad wins round number 2
Toby Toby do well
character so many legendary star
characters and role players to consider
here I might need more time to think
I don't know gang sounds like this could
be the start of a mystery ok so where do
we begin let's get the core starters
involved first Sam Dean
you guys are up Jared Padalecki and
Jensen Ackles have the kind of chemistry
that scientists and lab coats crave they
play off each other so well even when
they're having fun introducing
themselves under any of their myriad
pseudonyms I'm Dean Winchester I'm
looking for the devil's son this badge
is a fake they've even used fake
monikers referencing van Halen and
Metallica so you know that's an easy
early point for Supernatural in this
round whether it's their powerful bro
hugs their willingness to sacrifice
themselves for each other or just
karaoke perfection
[Music]
Sam and Dean make for amazingly sturdy
anchors of the show Wow but scooby-doo
and Shaggy are icons they debuted in the
summer of love and audiences over the
world have been swooned ever since
Scooby's plucky optimism mesh is so well
with Shaggy's fearful reluctance and the
two always meet in the middle with their
common love of food but let's not forget
the other trio who spent decades in the
hallowed Mystery Machine Fred Velma and
Daphne Fred takes his role as being a
nerdy do-gooder dressed like a preppy
frat boy in stride and he loves
splitting up it's like his favorite
pastime Daphne and Velma when their
unique abilities as amateur detectives
and all told the gang has rounded up a
grand total of 392 villains
yeah I accounted I have that kind of
free time these days supernatural has
also had a blast introducing characters
who expanded from becoming mere role
players into regularly occurring cast
members
how about Castiel's entrance in season 4
hey assbutt Mary Winchester and John
Winchester also factored prominently and
the show is further bolstered by
memorable turns from famous people like
Felicia Day and sterling K Brown then
you have the characters that surround
the mystery gang okay here's the good
news first
memorable cameos have been a staple of
scooby-doo since the beginning everyone
from
monkeys - mama castor the Harlem
Globetrotters have enjoyed the company
of Scooby and Norville did you know that
was Shaggy's real name was uh was
Norville I probably go by Shaggy too but
look I can't let the mystery gang off
the hook that easy there's an elephant
in the room and it's Scooby's nephew to
put it gently not well-liked I myself
have a confounding relationship was
crappy because as a kid I thought he was
great he was maybe my favorite character
on the show and then you know I became
an adult and the thing is seeing
scooby-doo as an adult I watched the
show and I was saying scrappy is the
most annoying character I've ever seen
in my life it's hard to make me not like
a dog
it's like scrappy do and what other
hated dog is there ever I was even cool
with Poochie from The Simpsons the Taco
Bell Chihuahua sure scrappy-doo
no thank you there was also a Scooby dum
and a dooby doo which I'm pretty sure
Shaggy tried to smoke over all it's a
tough call here but there's no contest
in terms of role players supernatural
has solid contributors coming off the
bench every season and they never had a
scrappy-doo I'm trying to think of any
other dog that I disliked even the
replacement Brian on Family Guy at least
had a funny line here there but if we're
looking at a truly iconic core cast you
can't ignore the staying power a Fred
Daphne Velma Shaggy and of course
Scooby they're underrated as detectives
and even if they aren't as cool as Sam
and Dean they're endlessly entertaining
to watch in the tightest round yet I'm
gonna give the win to Scooby in the gang
and they're up to to one wildcard round
villains okay I know what you're
thinking mark don't villains just count
as characters technically yes but the
big baddies are such an integral part of
both shows that they deserve their own
category Wow
that was garyun the name of the show
Supernatural says it all you got your
classic ghosts and ghouls vampires
werewolves but there's also really
freaky stuff that I'm glad I never heard
of when I was a child how about the
darkness no this is not the thing called
love in fact it's the older sister of
God of God and she ain't happy her
little bro gets all the credit
you got the Horsemen of the Apocalypse
leviathans Duchenne's who I actually
have heard of thanks to Magic the
Gathering what's really cool about each
film that they take on is the backstory
that we get the nod to mythology is one
of the most intriguing aspects of
supernatural you get the siren or the
croc kata which mimics human voices to
draw in its prey and this isn't to
mention all the other demons you got
your changelings get your hellhounds the
Winchesters have had to deal with these
things on a regular basis
listen filmer this isn't the Scooby Gang
so how does scooby-doo answer well what
you may think scooby-doo is just a
kid-friendly show but listen to this
roster of baddies ape-man Viking ghost
no-face zombie Phantom virus
hey that's topical and you also had your
sillier variety like Cat Man ghost clown
the Loch Ness monster which actually
turned out to be a vehicle yeah the big
obstacle the mystery gang faces in this
round is the lack of a recurring threat
Supernatural had some all-time baddies
coming back for more Crowley vacillated
between villain and antihero but was
always a captivating watch and willeth
eventually reached her goal of
destroying the 66 box keeping Lucifer it
back and Lucifer himself well as you
might imagine he tortured poor Sam so
much he had to go to the psych ward
the only real counter Scooby has in this
round is if we the audience can consider
scrappy-doo a villain I think a lot of
people out there would he's certainly a
show ruiner but he did try as best
okay fine scrappy you're not a villain
but you're just super annoying the
reason I respect both squads of demon
deflecting detectives is their continued
ability to take on cases no one else
would most humans and/or canines would
be too afraid to battle any of these
creatures and that's only if they even
believed in them at all I'm gonna go
stuff the big bad wolf
which is the weirdest thing I've ever
said the mystery gang and the
Winchesters had faith to fight the
scariest things on earth or elsewhere
the big difference is it's scooby's team
usually found out the big scary thing
they were facing was just some old town
kook some older fella who didn't like
the last meal government cheese the city
served him and so he decided to get
revenge and he would have gotten away
with it if it wasn't for you meddling
kids the meddlesome kids named Sam and
Dean on the other hand they fought these
scariest actual villains imaginable and
that's why they get the win in the
wild-card round the Winchesters take it
and it's all tied up at two know what
you're awesome and now we're at the
point in the show where your fearless
host has to render a verdict and break
this tie but first then you know about
the legendary crossovers episode of
Supernatural that involves scooby-doo
and his team they called it a Scooby
natural episode and one of the many
highlights is that we get to see sort of
a showdown between two celebrated
vehicles so the Winchesters they have
their 67 Chevelle it's a classic and if
you're a gearhead you know that then can
pack some serious punch but it actually
gets outran by the mystery machine in
that episode
so maybe the van was powered by
unwavering optimism or a nitrous oxide
boost but it did win the race so is that
enough to give scooby-doo the win today
okay look both teams deserve our respect
they've outlasted countless witches and
ghosts and the most ridiculous monsters
you could think of and they managed to
entertain us consistently in the process
they're both Titans of the world of the
supernatural but only one can be called
truly iconic scooby-doo and his pals
I've been crushing the game for more
than 50 years and they've entertained us
all and the time we were we Little Tikes
all the way through our adult years in a
recent survey rancor listed scooby Doo
as the number one greatest cartoon
character in history now I'm a fan of
Sam and Dean but could they have taken
down the likes of Bugs Bunny or Homer
Simpson I don't
think so I think even hardcore defenders
of Supernatural will admit that we all
owe a tip of the cap or a tug of the
Ascot to the mystery gang take a bullet
for that dog without them generations of
kids may never have gotten as invested
in supernatural or and who knows if any
of these other shows or movies that we
take for granted today would have gotten
made did you believe me when I said I
thought we could win this thing nope
hold the phone jeepers jinkies two weeks
okay so scooby-doo gets the win but
that's just our opinion now it's your
turn heads in the comments right now and
vote for who you think is the best
supernatural poltergeist babblers of all
time okay we're gonna say good night
everybody keep wearing those asking nuts
just putting puts the Scooby Snack
we'll see it next time here on the show
like
[Music]